Oh,
sweet bitches.
Here we go again.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
audible.com.
If you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you will get one free audio book and you can try audible free for 30 days.
It's a bad ass service.
It's one of the coolest ways to spend time,
whether it's in traffic or stuck on a train somewhere in a plane or whenever
you're just forced to just sit there.
It makes that time so much better to have a good audio book.
Um,
it just,
uh,
I've been a fan of audio books forever and audible is taken to the next level
with this thing they have called whisper sync and this is in an application they
developed for the kindle fire Hd.
And what it is,
is when you're reading a book,
you read a book on the kindle and say like,
you get to page 10 and you fall asleep when you get up in the morning and get in
your car,
your car will start playing an audio version of the book right where you left
off.
It's such a cool move.
I'm a huge,
huge fan of that and Brian is pulling up hooker books,
which I don't think you should be reading because those books are boring.
Hooker book read to you.
Are you kidding me?
You buy some old bitch whose mouth is all like sandpaper from a million Dick's
been in there.
Does every year and under homeland ander
Oh,
I think she's psychic Xavier Hollander.
She was like,
when I was in like high school,
she was like one of those first like b movie freaks that would like do like show
time,
2:00 in the morning movies.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They have these terrible like cinemax movies.
Bunch of those.
Like she would always like,
oh my God,
I can't believe this happening.
Like find yourself in a fucking closet with some dude fingering her.
Well,
what's cool is that you can play samples on audible so you can get a sample of
the narration to.
So we can listen to a little bit of this happy guide to hookers.
Sex.
I would say we got have mind blowing sex and if you follow the advice here in
that's not a hooker operator is terrible.
Please,
please stick my mouth on your penis.
You will not find advice in here about how to attract and seduce it.
Mate.
Oh,
that is a woman who's made entirely out of mayonnaise.
That was so you could get any audible audio book.
Do you have already a book?
No,
I don't have it on me.
I got my audio book.
I don't know
my own audio book.
What is it?
The,
uh,
the name of the book?
Fresh off the bush off the boat.
Let's see.
Pull it up,
Brian,
to see if they have like some hooker reading it.
Oh Shit.
That's me.
But you didn't read.
Did you read it?
Read it.
They wouldn't have it with somebody else.
That would be insulting.
I mean they did for
the dude just sucks it.
Reading his own book.
I asked for William Hung.
I was like,
I don't read the book.
Be what happened to that dude.
Should we tell the waiter we should send these back?
Oh Dude,
you're,
you're better at talking sexton.
That check.
Was that reading your own book?
Like was that like a long process or was it kind of like,
oh it's Kinda cool I get to read this whole book through?
No,
it was,
it was weird,
but I'm reading it was cool because I had only read my book twice when I edited
it.
So for reading the audio was the third time I read the book it's like,
Oh,
this is dope book.
It was funny,
but it is weird to hear your own voice.
It takes like a half day to be like,
that's my fucking voice.
You get used to that shit.
I'm so go to audible.com forward slash joe and you can pick up that book by
Eddie Huang.
How you say it.
Hey Ang,
anyone,
anyone a fresh off the boat,
a memoir.
So go do it.
It's free.
How do you go wrong?
You can't go wrong with audible.
They're cool and they're our sponsor.
We're also sponsored by [inaudible] DOT com.
That's o n n I t go and get yourself some kettlebells,
bitch and become a more manly fied version of yourself.
We've got everything you need between supplements,
um,
strength and conditioning equipment.
We got DVD,
exercise,
dvds,
blenders for making Kale shakes.
We just try to sell you the coolest Shit we could possibly find when it comes to
health,
fitness and wellness.
And if you use the code name Rogan,
you will save yourself 10 percent off any supplements.
You dirty bitches.
Eddie Wong is here.
Let's get the party going.
Isn't it phonetic?
The Way Chinese to spelling?
Like the way you say your name long,
you picked an interesting way.
H U a N G A N G?
Yeah.
It should be.
Just be like w o n,
g,
yeah.
Yeah.
It should be.
No,
the Cantonese way is w o n,
g and then the silly mandarin people spelled it her way and she silly is.
It does not sound like.
Yeah.
It's tricky though.
And you're going from characters.
Hit it.
Brian,
play the music,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Powerful.
Eddie Wong is in the building.
That's h u a n g people,
people searching,
W O,
n,
g like us,
silly,
uninformed Americans.
It is funny that I'm like,
they have to change those,
those characters and to translate your name into English and put it into a sound
and for different people at disputes on how you should do that.
It's fucking crazy because it's like taking a photo and being like,
how's that photo sound home?
You know,
like it's pretty impossible
that.
Yeah.
Well,
with the way you said that,
it's like taking a photo because the way you guys look at like language,
the Chinese competitors totally different.
It's a different way of looking at the whole world.
Yeah,
that's a mind fuck and a half right?
It's kind of caveman steve because it's like,
all right,
I want to say this,
I'm going to draw it out,
you know,
kind of.
It's cool.
It's very like,
it's an artistic fucking language.
Definitely like it a lot.
Well,
it's good.
It looks good on people when you talk to it too.
But the funniest shit is like white boy Asian tattoos.
Like see what duties,
like,
Hey,
what's the same motherfucker that says energy on your arm?
Like you're like a red bull ahead.
You wrote energy on your arm.
The digital and mobile energy positivity.
I'm all about putting on my consciousness to the universe.
The Chinese tattoos.
They say that the Gypson language of hieroglyphs is an even bigger mind fuck.
Because they,
they see everything in these,
like these symbols,
you know,
and that we are the way Americans and people read English language the way we
look at.
Just even like the way you'll,
you'll look at sentences.
It's completely different than if you tried to read like hieroglyphics.
Yeah.
I mean I don't read hieroglyphics,
but I heard that shit is mad hard.
They needed this stone for it.
The Rosetta stone.
Yeah,
they did.
Yeah.
Hieroglyphics or some shit,
if that's even more caveman than,
than Mandarin.
Chinese like Chinese is almost like refined hieroglyphics,
but it still makes no sense.
Well,
the fascinating
thing about the,
uh,
the hieroglyphics is that they depict all of the Pharaohs and they depict them
from this whatever dynasty.
The,
um,
you know,
the last pharaohs existed in to what gets into like fiction,
they think like 30,000 years.
Like then they live in like hundreds years long and they're fucking 10 feet
tall.
It gets like real wacky,
like as shit gets like super,
super old know the stories got more and more screwy before anybody bothered to
write them down.
So it makes you wonder like,
man,
how long has that hieroglyphs writing actually been around?
You know,
Yo man,
salad tossing,
Yoshi did give me the heads up bogus.
Yo.
She reads a lot of books.
Motherfucker.
Joe Rogan is a smart motherfucker.
Well I'm just fascinated by weird shit like the Egyptian culture Egypt in
culture.
That's the cradle,
you know what I mean?
That's where everybody came from.
Supposedly.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
the only issue is that there's some new shit they've been finding that's even
older than that.
The real question when it gets to like something like Egypt or anywhere we've
had some really,
really old shit is like,
what happens if you find shit that's way older and what do you do then?
Like you can't say the Egypt was like the oldest,
like really advanced culture when you find like go back lay tappy which is in
Turkey,
which is 14,000 years old.
It's so much earlier than Egypt
but not earlier than Africa in general.
Like the out of Africa theory,
right or happy
is right now the oldest known complex structure that a human has ever pilled and
they know that it's at least 14,000 years old.
That's fucking crazy.
And not only that,
they know that it existed for thousands of years before it was intentionally
covered and they've only.
I think as of right now,
they've only uncovered like five percent of the entire structure and it's
enormous and there's a series of circles and stones,
but they've done whatever they do with radio waves or whatever they do to to map
out what's going on under the surface and they've determined that it's massive.
That's awesome.
Fourteen thousand years ago,
so that's even older than than Egypt,
you know?
That's insane.
You know that something was happening in Turkey before.
It's something huge,
not just something he doesn't like.
A 14 foot stone columns that had been caught and moved hundreds of tons of
stone.
I mean,
these are like,
this is advanced construction.
It doesn't dispel out of Africa though,
right?
It doesn't necessarily.
No,
no,
because 14,000 years ago it's still ain't shit.
We're talking about human beings coming out of Africa and migraines.
It's like millions.
Yeah.
It's like,
what is a human,
you know,
it gets too low.
Is it Jack Enemy?
Which,
uh,
which different Australia pythagoreous like at what point in time do you decided
to early human because at one point in time it's like fucking the media and it
goes from Amoeba to being a lower primate and to being a higher primate.
When is that?
That's true.
It's all how you frame it because the people,
you know,
you wouldn't want to hang out with Australia,
Perth against the guy that's fucking idiots.
They're going to be a monkey man eating his own shit and fucking try to kill
your cat.
And that's not a human.
You know,
it'd be like almost a human,
you know.
But I think I'm civilization in Mesopotamia was a looks super advanced.
They know like 6,000 years ago in Turkey now being 14,000 years still,
I could go back to like 30,000 years and that ain't shit in terms of the history
of the earth and that would be insane for us to think that 30,000 years ago they
had like complex cities,
but it's super positive.
Yo,
I was talking to someone this week at Ted two.
She was a cosmologist and she was telling me that life can survive on Mars and
then people you can actually,
if you're willing to commit,
they will take you to Mars and you can be part of the.
If someone was saying,
Joe,
I could put you on a space shuttle.
You could go to Mars and you can be part of the first colony and you could
basically be the fucking gang gets kind of Mars.
Would you do it?
No,
it's stupid because Mars is just like a shitty apartment on earth.
That's what it's like.
It's like a shitty apartment that you can't get out of.
Once you get there,
that's where you're stuck.
You can't go outside and there's no oxygen.
You've got to terraform and put a dome over it.
Life can survive out there at night without that shit.
She's march of Mars.
Know that she believes can sustain life.
No,
she's silly.
That's not correct.
But hypothetic mean.
I don't say it's correct.
Like,
okay.
Hypothetically you,
let's say it was correct,
let's say who it was,
but it would have to be a very small area because most of Mars doesn't have.
Is it possible that the,
uh,
the atmosphere would vary that much with one part would be sustainable,
so alien to me?
Sure.
She wasn't talking about terraforming.
No,
she was talking about,
she said life can sustain on Morris.
She was telling me but as it is.
And then she showed me a media.
Right?
I was like,
okay.
I kind of got fucked up by the show and tell because they're short sell,
kind of fucking threw me off.
I was like,
Damn,
you got a rock from there.
Terraforming means when you go to,
um,
a inhospitable climate and set up machines to click in the movie alien,
right?
Yeah.
I don't see how there's any other way to live on Mars.
Other than that,
I don't think that atmosphere is thick enough.
That would be scary if those machines broke one day or something.
Everyone died at once and died.
Slovis fixation.
When this air slowly gets eaten up by,
you know,
if someone told me you could go to Mars and there's everything you need and it's
terraforming and con Ed was in charge,
I would never fucking go.
Listen man.
Even if he will have con ed in La Obviously,
but in New York kind of fucks everything up.
We have the same thing.
It's like,
I don't even fuck shit up.
Fucking who fucks it up,
your electricity.
The other function of Edison,
the
La was famous for the brownouts back in the day where they just started shutting
power up and basically they didn't have to do it.
They were doing.
It was.
It was all agreed thing.
Somehow or another,
it was a.
They were making a fuck load of money doing that.
I don't remember what the scam was,
but people I believe lost their job and even went to jail for that shit.
Those brownouts yeah,
no,
but Mars.
I was thinking that,
man,
I don't want to go to my.
She said you can go,
but you can never come back.
I was like,
okay,
let me ask you this.
Would you go to the desert?
Would you go to the middle of the Sahara where there ain't shit.
It's dangerous and you could die out there for no reason but never to stay
forever,
but that's Mars.
Mars is just like going out into the mojave.
Ain't shit out there.
What she said though,
she said mad people from her classes and the other professor she knows wanted to
go.
They were all wanting to sign up to go to Mars and you got to be egotistical
motherfucker to be like,
I want it to be the first one on this bullshit planet.
Well,
some people are silly.
That's a silly thing to do to go to another planet where you can't get back.
Fuck that.
Especially if like lance bass is going,
isn't he the one that's out in space and shit,
the backstreet boys or instinct dude in space is,
uh,
is he out in space?
He's trying.
One of the first ones he was.
Oh,
he has got right.
And did it with like the Russian cosmonauts,
right?
I think so.
Yeah.
No,
if they were like,
you got to go to Mars and Lance Bass is that I will not fucking horrible lance
baskets,
good foot massages.
Oh really cool to hang out with.
Oh,
you got a foot massage from lance bass.
I said,
maybe I'm just saying I think you're onto something better than you know,
going by yourself.
Tomorrow's,
you know,
maybe lance passes a hell of a conversationalist and halfway through the six
month trip you're like,
you know,
this guy's starting to fucking grow on me.
He's like the White Lloyd from entourage.
I ever watched the same here.
It was a horrible show.
I only watched it.
What happened to the Asian?
And I don't know if it was a fair representative of the show.
I only it once and I was like,
what the fuck's going on here?
Well,
who?
What are they watching?
Well,
isn't the Asian gay?
He was mad gay.
A lot of.
Yeah.
Would you go to Mars?
Would you?
If you could,
if you knew it was dope.
If you knew it was like Alaska in the summer,
just beautiful green
like they have the Bush company.
I would go,
you know?
No.
If I could go to Mars and come back.
If you could go and come back,
go and come back.
But it was only a 90 percent chance of success.
Success meaning like life life coming back like 10 percent possibility that
there might be a fucking solar flare while you're in the middle of the flight
back and everybody in the
playing guitar.
I wouldn't need a 100 percent like I'm not.
I'm not dude that I won't even get laser eye surgery.
One hundred percent.
Like my brothers all got laser eye surgery.
I was like,
you Chinese,
you should not be fucking with your eyes.
You already fucked up and now you're going to introduce this new element of
surgery.
Hell No.
Well they're supposedly had it down pretty good.
At what level will you be willing to do it?
Like 200 percent.
Two hundred percent.
Yeah.
I don't think that's how could they do?
No,
it wouldn't need to be 100 percent that 100 percent back
a hundred percent.
You know,
come from New York to La.
You might as well.
Look,
if it was at 97 percent,
I will go.
I'll deal with a three percent plus minus.
I would imagine that if people keep going the way we're going now and a thousand
years from now getting to Mars will be just like going to New York.
Oh,
that would be awesome.
If we don't blow each other up in a thousand years,
just imagine what we've done in 200 years and a thousand years.
There'll be plane flights tomorrow.
It'll be so fast.
Like five hours later you're on Mars.
Did you say your present was seven percent?
90 seven.
Oh,
nice.
Yeah,
I would love to go.
I just want to see that shit.
Um,
if you had a choice between going to another planet or going back in time,
oh,
that's a good call because going back in time you kind of know what you could
see.
But man,
going back in time,
I would probably,
you know,
I would want to go to Mars because going back in time,
the other times we've had,
it's like less amenable.
Do you know what I mean?
Like there's more diseases.
You don't get killed as easily.
Like you get shanked you know when you die back in the day,
you get shanked.
It's not like a bullet in the head.
You could die easily.
Now I would rather go to the future then go backwards for safety sake.
Not just safety sake,
but I want to see the next shit.
There's not really,
I'm not like woody Allen where there's a period of time I would love to Tony's
parents,
you know,
would love to be alone to 30 to tell you,
like hell no man,
like motherfuckers didn't have ac.
A few.
I would way rather see the future,
like a peek at the future.
Then a peak at the past,
but if it had,
if I had to choose between going to Mars or going to the past,
I think the past,
without a doubt,
I would love to see how people lived thousands of years ago.
Yeah,
man.
To just peek in on gang is con.
Oh hell yeah.
How fucked up.
So heavy going.
I thought about it.
I would ride with gang gets caught.
I'd be motherfucking I arrived for you like pull up in a tank,
a tank light.
These motherfuckers on fire with machine guns.
They don't know what's going on and you will be the king.
You Suck my dick in front of everybody.
I want to go back in time with a fucking like ipad and be with gangs like Yo,
you're the original rough rider.
You're like dmx before 10 motherfucker.
You the fucking Chinky idea.
Max.
I want to film this shit and make a rough riders video with the volume
Mongolians on horses and fucking crossbows and shit would make you eat your own
calves and calf off and make you cook it and eat it.
He would rob me for my ipad and throw me in a part
of a gang has come with suck dude.
Either fuck my mom and be like,
I want a genetically duplicate myself in your mom or chop me up and put me in a
pie.
I've been listening to a Dan Carlin Columbian barbecue by as Dan Carlin was a,
the um,
uh,
the,
our grit,
our guests on Monday and he has a podcast called hardcore history and right now
it's all about the Mongols.
That's all he's been talking to
about
civilization ever barbecue.
Listen,
man style.
It's like meat over fire because that's what you do when you're raping and
killing people.
That baby corn,
that Mongolians habits,
so amazing.
Peaky core and what is it about being in court and so much more exciting than
regular that Mongolian produce,
that fucking baby corn,
the,
the story of the,
of the Mongols and how much they accomplished and they took over countries and
then they would force the people in that country to go with them to war and they
would become soldiers like they would invade Poland and steel Polish people.
They made French people fight against other Europeans.
They just think,
oh bitch,
you're coming with us and you're going to be us now.
What are you going to do?
You got to fight for us.
You're going to die right now.
Are going to take a fight,
and they just start fighting other people.
They incorporate them into their army.
Like they had crazy to join their crew.
Everyone joined the crew and it was like he was basically Drogo from game of
thrones in real life,
but even more fucked up because after,
after you would conquer like the people that were left,
they would say,
okay,
congratulations.
We won.
There's no one left to kill,
so you're free to go,
and then the three miles later they'd fucking run them down and hacked them to
bits.
Wow,
dude,
this Dan Carlin,
the guy is,
he's a trip man.
He's a serious historian and especially this,
this whole period that he's going over right now.
It's fucking great to make the live in 1200.
You know,
Jesus Christ,
the Nutty Shit that that guy was going through.
Just they said that some insane percentage of the population of that area has
his DNA.
He's the most duplicated man in the world.
Ever.
Ever,
ever.
If there's one person I love myself,
I'm not an egotist could do,
but I do kind of like myself.
If I could be any other man though,
it will be gang as cotton.
No doubt.
Like I wouldn't think twice.
Gangas con is the hardest motherfucker ever.
He got a lot,
but you wouldn't want to be.
He was so he was like a crossbow.
You went back in time like that though.
You couldn't be that mean.
Why are we torturing everybody?
But that's so much pussy too.
I mean that was tons of pussy.
Well it was,
it was constant.
It was constant pussy.
Yeah.
They would steal each other's wives and shit.
Back then,
like dudes were just,
it was.
We were like,
chimps with swords,
you know,
that's what human beings for like if you could give champs a bunch of swords,
they would do terrible,
horrible shit.
You know,
we don't think about human beings as being capable of doing terrible,
horrible shit.
But even today,
if you look at some of the accounts of what's going on in North Korea,
those North Korea and Syria,
Syria,
home,
man,
it's bad.
There's parts of the world ever.
There's always going to be parts of the world where it's terrible and people are
capable in those parts of the world of doing shit that you only read about in
history books.
Rodman going to North Korea.
Insane.
Yes.
I tweeted that today.
Is he out of his fucking mind out or no man,
they're not going to like him in North Korea.
I don't think he understands what North Korea is.
He's going over there to do some sort of a Harlem Grope.
Globe trotters style.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
Americans can't really wrap their head around how fucked up
it's fucked up so far.
It's Nazi Germany.
Yeah.
Just like.
I was going to say that you're walking into like there's country.
It's crazy.
The whole country.
Anyone want to leave the kill at the board?
Oh yeah.
And there's so many slaves.
They have so many slaves and they have these slave colonies where they're making
these people work for like a half a bowl of rice a day.
They're starving to death.
They keep them just barely above starving that.
They beat them to death constantly.
They feed them to dogs.
Like people that have escaped have told stories.
There's the human rights violations that we're hearing from North Korea,
like,
oh,
that shit about going to Iraq because we're going over there to fucking protect
lives and enforce democracy.
If we really wanted to protect lives,
we would be in North Korea right now.
It will be North Korea.
We'd be in Syria.
Yeah,
you're right.
Those that don't that place,
especially North Korea,
I'm more familiar with that than I am with what's going on in Syria,
but North Korea is a mess right now.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Our our country is not a country that's out there benevolently in country.
It's just really to protect the business interests at hand and I'm like,
that's one of the things like,
you know,
which movie did you want to win?
The Oscar.
I'm curious.
I don't give a fuck about.
I think that awards for art or some of the dumbest is to judge the judge are.
I'm interested though,
just because I'm like,
well,
they pick the right one this year.
Do you know what I mean?
I'm really curious to see if one day they'll do the right thing because I was
like,
Django was the best shit out.
A Django was the hardest movie out this year.
It should have won.
That was a great movie.
He goes three hours and never lost my intention.
I know that movie kept me going the whole time to do argo.
Right.
You just basically recreating some shit that happened.
You're a to see both of those movies.
The problem with those movies is they're based on real events and they add a
bunch of bullshit and it's not real.
They add a bunch of bullshit to them and when you add a bunch of bullshit like,
like the woman that was responsible for everything and zero dark 30 that made
the whole thing happened,
you're going to go kill him.
For me,
that bitch didn't exist.
No,
she's not a real human.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
It's like you can't just add people to historical movies.
That's crazy.
Unless if someone was going to find in Latin,
it wouldn't be a ginger.
It might be the good decks.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
look,
the lady was a great actor.
The movie was very well done,
but I call shenanigans.
You can't just create a fucking fictional character that figures it all out and
there was no George Bush like,
you're going to do the whole fucking movie with no dumb ass.
George fucking it up.
The whole thing was weird.
It was weird.
It was a weird movie,
man.
It was a very weird movie,
but I remember watching jangled.
I was like,
if this shit doesn't win the Oscars,
it's bullshit.
The Oscars is.
It is every year.
It's.
It's ridiculous.
The titanic was not a good movie.
Not a good movie.
It was good.
That was good about titanic.
Special effects were fucking incredible.
It was amazing.
It was a vehicle for showing what's possible cinematically with special effects
in 19 whatever the fuck it was.
90 something to hear you talk about it,
but as far as like a script,
it's like really obvious,
you know,
it was hot trash,
more obvious than Avatar.
Avatar was knocked for being obvious,
but I thought Avatar was even more creative with like the crazy plants that you
can plug into.
The screenplay was slightly better,
slightly better,
and also avatar was actually like in terms of special effects,
even more progressive,
even more avatar was on some shit.
It's almost like what Cameron's movies are.
It's like they're like,
he doesn't stray too far from the path when it comes to like a storyline,
but he provides you with the state of the art shit.
He takes the bar and just just blows it through the stratosphere.
No one came close to avatar yet.
Then movie's insane.
The visual experience,
especially if you go to imax three,
a motherfucker,
man,
just one of those dudes were popping out of their little sleep tanks and
floating through the air and you're like,
this,
this movie is bad has.
Yeah.
I remember when I saw up in,
it was in three d and I was like this the worst use of three d ever.
Like it just made the Asian Kid Chubbier
yeah,
there's some movies that don't really do a good job with it.
But avatar was stunning.
It was.
It was more than just a movie.
I mean,
two best movies this year was fucking Django
and wreck it.
Ralph wreck it.
Ralph was making movies.
I didn't even know what you're talking about.
You got to watch.
What is it?
You know,
you will never have all your favorite characters from fucking video games in a
video game world.
And it's animated feature about all your favorite video game.
He might not like it because he's not that big into the video games.
This was,
this was a release in the film.
Is this Disney?
Maybe Sarah Silverman is in it.
Uh,
John C dot reilly.
Hey.
Yeah.
It wasn't
until just now.
Yeah.
God Damn with.
There's too much to know.
Walk it,
watch it.
Watch it with the chick.
That's the closest one to being your best chicken.
You're stable way.
You should watch them when I would recommend watching it with your kids.
They might like it.
You think so?
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
Record.
It's all good.
It's got a car.
I haven't even heard of it before.
Oh,
it's on itunes right now.
That's crazy,
man.
When something is bad asking you haven't even heard of it from street fighters
and.
Yeah,
that's the best is when you're like,
wait,
that missed me and now I have something to do this weekend.
Fuck yeah.
Who are we talking to recently?
They never heard of grizzly man and
we're like,
what?
I don't know.
Have you heard of the documentary?
I have.
No.
Damn it son.
How can we?
But I'm also Chinese.
One was this grizzly man fairly recently.
I kind of missed cultural thing six years ago.
Maybe something like that.
You usually man is a movie about a dude who lived bears.
Bears.
Yeah.
People told me about this,
but I was like,
I'm not interested.
It wasn't in the world journal.
Do you need a smoke a joint and watch this and laugh by bear.
Laugh your dick off at this silly,
silly bitch.
This guy might be the silliest bitch to ever go camping and yeah,
it was crazy and the bear ate him.
The end of the movie.
It's.
It's a fascinating.
It's because it's not meant to be funny.
It's a Werner Herzog film.
Oh,
okay.
It's not meant to be funny,
but it's just funny.
I mean it's,
it's like,
like the Perfect Cohen brothers movie.
You know how like Coen brothers movies.
It's like dark and exit.
Yeah,
accidentally.
Funny.
Almost.
It's like,
like Fargo Fargo's amazing.
Well,
yeah.
I didn't even understand Fargo till I was 20.
When you're younger and watching,
you're like,
why do they do this?
Fucking hate people
die.
All of you in the woodshop machine.
What you get used to people being bullshit artists.
That's when the salesman and his fucking coat become so much more entertaining.
When you run into like one of those bullshit salesmen is just trying so hard to
sell you this fucking bullshit that you spray on the bottom of your car.
You hit 19 and then you just want to see people die.
You want to see him die.
It's so unfortunate.
Why is that?
Not all of them.
Just the concept of the world.
Just a useless Fox clogging it up for everybody else.
Yup.
Yeah,
but that,
that movie was grizzly man is a must.
It's a must.
It's a must that you would like to recommend to people.
Do you have a must
that you tell people like you have to see this man?
I mean this year was record Ralph and Django,
but before that,
I mean it's been grizzly man since I saw it.
That's all I recommend to people,
man know those ones this year,
but no.
Yeah,
I don't have like a go to market
movie.
Can you imagine how big a grizzly bear is compared to that Werewolf out there?
Do you know Greg would fuck me up spirited boy.
Fuck you up at a grizzly would eat that werewolf a grizzly bear lake
pitch.
The grizzlies that were with me that a man that was fucking big,
great werewolf is like,
that's the only like seven feet long.
Have you seen spirited away?
Why don't you tell me what that is?
Spirited away is a animation that Japanese animated film.
Yeah,
and it's really,
really trippy and it's a real cool animation to see why you're really stone.
How old?
How old is this?
A 2001 I think.
Oh,
okay.
I think I have seen that.
Is that.
What's the guy's name?
Hey,
rocky or something.
Something like that is a good movie.
Is this a good way?
I do believe I've seen that.
Another way to think about it,
I think I have with the little girl and the big cat and the faces and stuff.
It's really cool.
Yeah,
I do.
I do think I've seen that.
Is that yours?
That's what of always.
That's one of my eye.
I have movies I can watch over and over and over again.
That's one of them,
like that's relaxing,
you know?
It does.
It can get annoying because it's so relaxing and calm and cool.
Know that's the opposite of grizzly man.
I thought Toronto was pretty cool to the neutron.
Did you really?
You would recommend that?
I wouldn't recommend it,
but I think that year I might've been.
That would have been in my handful of movies.
I just thought it was trippy to watch.
Well,
I think to use like it represented,
you know,
the old day,
the old fan,
if you're a fan,
I can see it,
but it was a piece of shit.
Yeah,
it was good to watch.
The special effects were weird.
It's like it was so obvious.
It wasn't really a young him.
It was like they did something to his face and turn them into young adults.
I mean,
I guess the one film I recommend that everyone is killa season.
Cameron's Killa season.
What does that do?
Well,
Santana's in all the dips at dudes are in it.
It's like the worst boots.
Oh,
you don't listen to the dip set.
Oh
Shit.
What the dip set is.
No,
y'all don't know the dip set.
Y'All don't know the depths of my grandfather's rolling over you.
These fucking kids don't know the depths just as my grandchild and y'all don't
pull your pants up.
I just put you on some shit,
Joe,
because you need to get diplomatic immunity.
One diplomatic immunity to watch killa season.
What am I killing?
Dominican women's shooting cocaine out of their assets.
It's awesome.
Did you guys.
I was going to bring this up yesterday.
Did you guys hear about this guy who got arrested with a hundred bags of heroin
up his ass?
Not hundred bags.
100 bags.
It was a traffic.
Stop this as hold him.
You have a sink hole in your pants or it's a 100 bags of heroin,
man.
100 man.
Oh.
Oh Jesus.
Okay.
I,
I look.
I look this killa season.
No,
no,
this one.
Okay.
This guy just had one.
This,
the other guy had it.
His ass.
One guy just had 200 bags.
I'm like,
did someone just take it to the next level and go 200 bags.
Oh,
there we are.
Wells right here.
This is from lots of my bag and this is a movie
like,
this is so amazing.
This is a terrible woman.
You're going to watch the
clock work.
Yeah.
This is like that asap rocky song.
They're playing right now.
Yes.
They are all from Harlem.
All these dudes.
Wow.
You gotta you gotTa Watch Killa season.
So this dude gets busted on the palisades parkway.
They pull them over in 2005 Mitsubishi Lancer and he's acting real weird and so
they decided to bring him in.
So they bring him in and they open up his ass.
They just gave him a cavity check.
I mean the guy didn't do anything wrong.
Then they pulled them over.
He just looked weird.
He was tweaking out on his own.
Something was going on with him.
Then he was pulled over.
I mean routine traffic stop.
But they,
they detected the smell of marijuana and that's where they,
that's where they got them and they brought him in because they smelled
marijuana.
That's it.
And he had 100 bags of heroin,
a disaster and you can't put 100 bags of heroin up your ass while the cops are
going from their car to your car.
You can't do that.
So he was driving around with those.
Packed up.
Is that.
Why would you drive around and smoke weed with 100 packs of heroin in your ass?
Well,
I think he's just one of those guys.
Maybe
like Russian chicks will put ben Wa balls and their pussy to tighten up their
muscles.
They're fuck muscle.
Maybe this dude was just like exercising his is asked or starfish that starfish
or maybe he didn't trust his roommates.
Like,
man,
if I leave this 100 bags of heroin,
what the fuck is?
He went to the gym.
She's like,
man,
I can't fit it in my pocket.
I can't leave.
I
can't leave it in my dash.
Let's work on that starfish.
The glove box is full
mate.
That just stuffed this up my ass.
Hmm.
Can I fit 100 bags?
Let's see.
Five.
Six.
Wow.
Am I really going to get 94 years?
Have you ever put anything up your ass like like a pill
or anything?
Ever
washcloth.
Finger finger on the end of a wash.
Washcloth.
I've never gotten.
Yeah,
I cleaned it out.
It seemed like a
little soap.
Little Polish.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I've never done that.
No view.
No.
I was just.
I've never even taken a thermometer.
The thermometer.
Yeah.
I had a doctors stick a finger up my ass.
I had to like,
when you're a kid,
when you have a fever,
they fucking put like advil in your ass.
I think it's.
I've never been into the girl putting the finger in my ass.
No,
no.
Never had that happen.
But they say it's amazing.
It's so I,
I just,
I don't want to go.
They're not gonna open.
That post will be amazing though.
It could be amazing prostate massage thing and Ugh,
shoot like a fucking broken fire hydrants.
Yeah.
I think you pretty much say
so.
The sponsor of the podcast
for backslash Joe Rogan finger up the.com.
I pinky
don't ask name.
Don't ask
third finger.
You can save yourself 10 percent off.
Embarrassment because a girl,
like if she's like,
you want me to put a second and finger?
And you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
What about third?
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
You're fucked up.
What's wrong with you?
You want three fingers up his ass.
Oh,
you need to get out.
Need a better man in your life.
You'll get out of Pittsburgh.
You've never had a girl try.
I've had to go try.
Always try.
Like jokingly said,
we never let it happen.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Never,
never.
Some cement.
That tickles.
It makes me feel gross.
I'm one of the people that believe or subscribe into the thing that,
uh,
that there's no.
You're not allowed to look at it.
You're not allowed to see it.
Smell it.
Touch it.
I don't want anything around my ass.
I don't know why.
Hey Man.
Whatever it is,
it's good.
It's probably a mess.
I mean,
I don't see
like grooming.
I don't see you getting down there with a fucking mirror.
And uh,
a big three blade.
Who has time for that?
Joe Polish and that area up nice.
Cleaning it up a company.
No.
But meanwhile
girls go in 69 and you her eyeball.
So like fucking inches away from that dirty disaster of an asshole of yours.
Do you let girls eat your ass?
Do you ever.
Have you ever had.
Never had that
have?
I've had girls get to the balls and the taint,
but I've never had a girl that nom nom nom
my ass.
And you get asked.
I've seen it in porn.
I've seen.
Yeah,
corn I've looked at certain things we can't discuss in this program with
websites is one of them.
I know.
I mean being the prior,
that's even less,
even less likely to be brought up a chicks don't want to hear about that.
So it was okay to eat before we were married.
I didn't even know you.
I didn't know you existed.
I ate a little ass before I knew you existed.
Whatever.
You couldn't have waited until it was the special one.
Even couldn't have waited.
Eating ass is something that came later to me in life.
Like,
you know,
like blue cheese,
you don't like blue cheese most of your life and one day you're like,
you know,
this is really good.
Like I didn't like eating out now.
I love eating the girl's ass.
It's one of my favorite things ever.
Well how long ago did this start?
Uh,
like,
like when you started dating freaks now as you went through the Brian Red Band,
you went into your brian red band freak period a few years back.
It's coincidentally right when we started doing this podcast.
Yeah,
I think it was right around that time.
Maybe you're right before
ducted into the world with girls with troubled childhoods.
And then boom,
we're off to the race 33,
33 or 34 years.
You were off to the races.
And the problem is when you,
you deal with like the world of Uber Freak,
professional sex workers essentially,
you know,
that's what you're dealing with.
And then to try to go from that to like some girl who was working on her
accounting degree,
you know,
it is it,
is there any hope?
Are you spoil,
right?
Yeah,
you're fucked.
Well,
you know,
look man,
let's be honest.
Your baton quite a bit over your head.
And uh,
that's hard to keep going in the regular world because in the regular world
girls will eventually get mad at you in the porn world.
They're just happy that they have a man.
Like they're happy that someone's there for them and someone loves them and
someone doesn't just treat them as something that just come inside of,
you know,
so they want to be cuddled and taken care of.
Really can watch nickelodeon.
You don't go watch nickelodeon.
Like once you've seen all the other shit,
you don't go watch nickelodeon.
I love Doug at the time,
but I don't want dog anymore.
There's,
there's a style
super sexual woman that you're only going to get from a chick that's like
probably willing to do porn.
Like a girl who wants to have threesomes with you.
Grow once,
eat your ass while you're fucking another guy or girl.
I'm just telling you,
you're going to have to go against what I'm trying to sound like.
It's not going to work out.
Get the final frontier for you.
For Real.
I think that like,
you know,
like if you just want to fuck,
okay.
And that's on it's way more fun to just date a bunch of freaks,
you know?
I mean,
if you're just trying to fuck the problem is if you want to really settle down
and have a relationship,
a lot of girls who have been involved in the adult industry in quotes,
they've vet a fucked up past and you're dealing with like,
do you think if a woman,
do you think if a woman's a Nympho and you date an info for like a year and a
half,
two years,
that,
that you would then become a Nympho because you have to be on her same.
It's like,
you know,
I think it's a theme park that you leave.
Yeah,
I like that.
That's a good way of looking at it.
Yeah.
Some girls,
there's some girls I dated a girl,
ones that couldn't come to,
couldn't come.
Like she never had orgasms,
but she wanted to fuck all the time.
It was craziness.
They want to keep trying,
but she couldn't do it like she did like and everybody says,
Oh,
you just didn't know how to make her come.
She didn't even know how to make her come.
Like nobody knew how to make her come.
She could never finger herself and make herself calm.
There was like one way where she could get herself to come,
but it was really hard and it didn't always work,
but it was
the whole thing was,
it was a real crazy sort of situation because you knew that sex feels good for
her,
but you always felt guilty because she couldn't come.
She'd get wet and shit.
She loved to fuck.
That was the crazy thing.
It's like something was off,
you know,
but she wanted to fuck all the time.
But if you date a girl who wants to fuck all the time and then you date a girl
doesn't want to fuck all the time,
especially if you're used to it and you like it,
you like,
um,
hey,
but you're awake and I'm awake and we're right here and we can just take our
clothes off and fuck it.
Why wouldn't we do that?
I don't want it.
Like,
whoa.
That doesn't even make sense to a dude.
No,
that's a useless.
That's a useless partner.
Yeah,
to a dude.
It's like,
we'll have.
The third thing is we supposed to be looking for as many opportunities as
possible to fuck.
That's why we're boyfriend,
girlfriend.
Right.
So what are we doing here?
You don't want to talk.
Okay.
You don't want to fuck,
but there's nothing holding you back.
You're not fucking talking and then you're in trouble.
But if nothing's holding you back,
like it's not like you have.
Like,
I would love to fuck right now,
but I have to go to work,
you know,
I have to leave.
I'm late.
That's one thing.
But if it's like,
oh,
I'm not in the mood.
Yeah,
okay.
You got to get rid of that.
Like the summer.
There's nothing on HBO and we're not fucking.
That's a problem.
Yeah,
you got to get rid of that.
That's,
that's where probably gay dudes understanding each other more better.
Like they probably,
they probably just give up the ass.
They tell you the guy at starbucks,
we were talking about Grindr.
Uh,
he,
he had the hat on.
Yeah,
because I had the hat.
I wear this grinder hat just for fun once in a while.
It's a bad idea.
But uh,
the guy goes,
oh man,
it's so funny.
You have the Grindr.
I use grindr every day.
He's like,
he's like,
I've used it three times this weekend so far.
And I was like,
what are you doing?
He goes,
oh,
it's just like,
hey,
there's a guy at pavilions down the street,
the grocery store he wants to,
he's down to fuck right now.
I could go with him,
we can go fuck in the car somewhere in a back alley or get a blow job.
And then I come back to work,
you know,
it's,
wow.
They're lucky.
Well you can definitely look at it that way,
but they have the.
But during the Dick.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a fail.
Yeah.
I mean don't you think about that even when a girl's willing to fuck you,
like when you have sex with your girl?
Don't.
I always think like,
why do you like Dick?
Like,
what is going on here?
Why do you like dudes?
Like,
what?
Why would you like a guy?
Like,
I don't get it.
I don't understand the attraction to a man,
you know?
So when I'm just glad they liked it,
medium,
Asian,
Dick.
Not saying that there's anything wrong
with,
you know,
being a heterosexual woman.
All I'm saying is I don't understand it.
Just like you wouldn't understand like being a gay dude either,
but if you were so afflicted with that predilection and you did,
that's what you enjoyed?
Yeah,
I would,
I would imagine that's a freer life.
I,
I just,
I just loved that they love it.
Like I'm really glad you liked the shit because I got a lot of it.
There's a,
there's a gay couple down the street from me and they're like trying to fit in.
I mean they do fit in great neighbors but they're trying to fit in like a
regular family.
Like they adopted a kid and you know,
they,
they do all the same shit that regular families do.
You know,
not that there's anything unregular about what is something unregular about two
gay dudes obviously,
but as one of them can't get pregnant,
it's totally great.
The thing is is like you shouldn't try to fit in like you're Asian,
you're black,
you're gay.
Like just be.
That was great,
but I mean when,
I mean by trying to fit in,
I shouldn't have probably said it that way,
but what I meant was that there,
you know,
they live like a normal family.
They're like they're gay married couple with a kid,
you know,
a lot of people have a hard time with that man.
It's,
it's really interesting.
But I think here like California is probably as loose as it gets with how people
like view that.
I don't know what kind of grief they catch,
but all the people that I know around them are like totally normal with it,
but you know,
it's like if they wanted to,
any one of those guys could just drive down Santa Monica Boulevard,
just enter into one of those clubs.
Just pull your cock out and just get the grinder on,
get,
get the slap happy on.
Right.
I mean that's a,
there's no place like that for dudes now because there's no place like that for
guys where you can just guarantee that you could go and there'd be a bunch of
horny checks looking for dudes.
See,
in New York there are places like Bob in the lower east side,
you go and there's always like a fat chick waiting for you.
What is Bob?
Bob is like 500 square foot hip hop like lounge situation and the lower east
side.
They play all golden era.
Hip Hop.
You go in,
everyone's sweating,
dancing and you always get asked and Okcupid is amazing.
Like I,
I abused with Okcupid.
Okcupid is like a website.
You go on and you can literally,
people have boxes like just looking to fuck.
It's like Grindr for heterosexuals for any sexuals.
Like you could have three eyes and find some other fuck with three eyes and
wants to fuck.
Yeah,
but they're almost the same people.
If you go to Craig's list and just like look in your area,
like looking to fuck type girls and then sometimes there's a picture.
There's never been one that I've gone,
oh my God,
yes,
I need to fuck this girl that I've.
I've had one on Okcupid.
I found a unicorn that was pretty good.
They'll tell us like,
what happened?
It was bad,
it was dope,
it was dope.
I ended up taking this Unicorn to vegas once.
It was good.
It's a lot of fun.
Well,
I
think that they exist.
I know that there's probably a lot of girls that are super hot that would love
to freak a guy out like that.
A guy couldn't believe how hot they are and they just want to fuck.
There's a lot of crazy bitches like that.
There's a lot of them.
Well,
in New York there's a lot of girls at work and they don't have time to go out
and date and meet dudes and pick them and they're like,
you know what,
I just,
I just need to sit on something and you just sit on something and just needed to
get their dick on.
You know?
It's great.
It's would be great.
It's fucking awesome.
You guys need that,
do you?
Don't you have OK cupid out here.
I'm sure you have OK cupid here.
They have it in Boston.
Yeah.
Too many crazy bitches out here.
It's just too dangerous.
I get a positive outcome.
Positive HIV positive.
That is.
Did you hear about that dude?
That was a.
He was some Christian mingle and he was raping checks.
No Way.
Yeah.
He was picking them up on Christian mingle and raping them.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's dating sites vary theirj date.
Christian mingle.
Yup.
I want to go on j.
date juice.
Chicks Love Asians.
Do you think so?
What is it?
Chinese food thing.
Words.
Yeah,
like we serve them on Christmas.
There's no dick or general toes.
Like where do I go?
Chinese.
Mm.
Yes.
Jewish Turks.
J date.
I think they all know how to fuck really?
Well.
Two Jewish girls.
Yeah,
I really do.
I've hopped a awesome.
How many of you?
Probably like five and they've all been awesome.
Crazy.
The head game,
the Jewish head game is the best.
Yeah.
It's absolutely known Jewish girls.
Give the best head.
Yeah.
When they do it.
Yes.
Then there's that old joke.
How do you stop a Jewish check from blowing you?
Killer barrier.
Oh,
that's a good one.
Yeah.
I think it's,
isn't it because like they are,
so since they're young they're always said you have to only have sex with Jewish
people and you never supposed to be with anyone outside of your race.
And I think that's why they're so crazy in bed.
Maybe you think so.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm just guessing not as suppressed.
There's a,
there's a less suppression in that religion than there is like sexually in like
Catholicism and you know,
a lot of other Christian religions.
It might be the Hitler Christ am I wear all the time.
And he said,
I want to hate.
Fuck you.
I just figured they thought there was money in the Dick Sucking on it.
Hard enough.
Half dollars
first.
What are you doing?
Fuck,
face
me the fucking feed,
the live feed.
Jamie's over there playing with him.
So,
um,
yeah,
the first Jewish girl I did it,
I was 21.
That was first,
like pitch was not.
She was great.
I was like Whoa.
But she was like,
she was a woman.
I was 21,
she was 25,
she wasn't time.
That's a woman.
It wasn't a girl in the cougar was the first time I ever dated a woman as
opposed to like every chick that I dated before was 20.
One was like 19,
20,
like my age.
They were like little kids,
you know.
This girl was like,
you know,
college graduates,
serious woman had a career and was.
It was totally different.
Bang.
A chick like that.
It's a completely different experience.
Like they're not.
They're not shy.
No,
no.
I've never gotten older.
I've always gotten younger.
Yeah.
That was the only time I ever did.
Maybe one of the time.
One of the time I did it,
the girl was like a year older than me,
which is acceptable and I want to do a cougar once.
I just think I see some because there's so many hot cougars here in Los Angeles
to join a gym.
If you want to get a real cougar,
you got to join a gym.
I'm a teddy bear.
Teddy bear with muscles.
Joe.
No,
I'm saying if you want to really meet the ones that you actually want to fuck,
you got to meet the ones that are at the gym because the ones that go to the gym
or the ones who still have the plump passes and they're like 50.
I've seen tricks with great assets that are 50 and you can't believe it.
It's like God damn.
Why?
Because that bitch is addicted to spin class and she's in there the fuck
that girl drone.
I got the crazy ass.
Tighten up those muscles.
I'm talking about girls that have their home gyms at Malibu.
They don't leave the house.
I come to.
Those bitches are weak and they're going to pass out on you.
They're going to faint and fall and hit their fucking head on the marble and
then you're going to get charged with murder.
Trust me,
keep away from those pictures.
Keep away from those tired,
tired,
low blood sugar.
Melba bitches never leave the house.
Walk around their fucking sweat.
That's put your shoes on and get the fuck out of the house.
Like Pamela Anderson.
Yeah,
you don't want that one because I was lazy and that asked is gone a long gone
ass son.
She was a beautiful,
beautiful young lady,
but someone stole her ass when she hit about 43,
44 a Goblin came into the house.
Now she just looks crazy.
She looked like Barbara streisand.
Now,
isn't it weird how she women really beautiful woman.
If they get crazy with their looks fake.
If they start shooting shit in their face,
they go from being beautiful to being repulsive.
Yeah,
and it's not.
A lot of time they do it,
you know it's going to happen and they still do it.
Psychological Shit.
It's like,
like people that are anorexic and they can't help it.
They get just keep losing weight or big bodybuilder dudes,
big bodybuilder dudes like I've,
I've met guys that are huge and they,
they're scared to go outside.
They want to cover their body,
their muscles up like big puffy sweaters and shit because they don't want people
to know how,
how small they are.
Wow.
Yeah.
They get nutty.
Especially like those competitive ones.
People who like enter into bodybuilding competitions,
they never feel like they're big enough.
It's a dysmorphia body images,
some fucked up shit.
It's very psychologically like you have no idea how much it fucking controls
you.
We're lucky there's not a dick operation that you could do to your dick with a
chick dust or tense because
listen man,
I've researched it could take a piece of your foot either research he looking
into.
I researched today.
I'm happy with my dad.
I'll tell you right now.
So of the biggest dick in the world,
but
it's mine and I like it.
I like medium.
Dick is great,
but this.
I'm like the body dysmorphia that some women have.
Like there was a woman that I knew many,
many a year ago who had a ridiculously large breasts,
fake tits and she wanted to get a bigger and all of her friends,
like you can't do that.
Stop it.
Like you can't choose.
I just want them a little bigger.
Just a little bit.
I mean,
they were fucking huge.
There were crazy,
huge,
crazy,
crazy.
Who's.
They don't look crazy good.
No,
they look crazy bad.
Crazy.
It looked like they felt like a knee getting breast reductions make no sense to
me.
Like you're just giving money away.
Well,
I think for some girls I dated a girl who.
Yeah,
she had an.
Before I met her.
She had had a breast reduction.
She had enormous tits and even when I met her they were like d cups and I was
like,
oh my God,
they were bigger than this.
Like she had like back pain.
So she would get pinched nerves and shit.
Like they just can go numb,
but still I feel like you have tits that big things will happen for you.
You know,
other things will take care of.
Someone will come on and that's it.
It's not like they come fucking bean stocks and take it to the match.
If you have a herniated disc and I come on your back,
it doesn't help much.
Not doing anybody any good.
It's not like you're rubbing it in.
It's Vicks Vapor Rub,
heal the injury.
I've talked about this before that I know somebody who has that disease.
I don't remember the name of it,
where they're.
Your tits are crazy big like,
like they're almost worms,
like 10 scientists.
Titus of the tips.
Yeah,
exactly.
And it's so big that she,
if you look at her,
she looks like she's really fat,
but then she takes off her shirt and just holds up her tits.
It's like,
oh no,
it's all just tit and body like sand.
So how big would you say her?
Like twice a normal tip.
Uh,
I would say each one of her tits was probably a,
I don't know,
24 inches long and a 24 inch.
Probably each one weighed probably I'd say about 50 pounds.
Oh my God.
The poor girl,
she had 100 pounds.
She still has it too.
She,
she can't.
She has to get these like crazy browse made it sears where they have to make the
Bra.
I'm telling you that we're,
we're lucky there's not a dick operation like that where you can get bigger.
Dick.
Has Anybody ever had a Dick Reduction?
Zimmer Dude had like a 24 inch Dick and they'll listen.
No girls can suck this.
I'm tired of this bullshit.
Cut me down to 10.
I would never,
man,
I could have a three foot dick.
I would never cut that.
It's fucking excalibur.
Don't touch excalibur.
Who's going to fuck you?
You're going to have to have chicks.
I know that you have like a fucking three foot like baby arm.
You're going to have to only date chicks that fuck basketball players and had
their babies or kill 12 pound babies came out of there.
Now it's not even Kim Kardashian because she hasn't had a kid yet.
You need a girl who's had a bunch of babies,
so she talked to mom your giant months.
Just like a sinkhole.
Yeah.
That's the only thing you could be happy with because otherwise,
what are you going to do with three foot of deck?
I'll tell you what you're gonna do.
You're,
you're going to get frustrated.
You.
If I have a three foot dictum,
I would just walk outside with that shit like I'm tanning would,
but you would never be able to really use it.
You will.
You don't want a three foot can have girls to slide on top of it.
You know?
If you had a three foot dick,
there would be girls that would just want to check it out.
Just I just want to sit on it a little bit and trust me.
I know a couple of girls could probably put three foot inside of them airtight.
They would break.
They would break just like the guy who got fucked to death by the horse.
There's no way that would make it.
Dana could take three foot of Dick,
Dana Mostec.
Kira could take three foot.
She where she wouldn't break.
She would die.
And you'd be one of those girls that did son of Dong.
They could take it.
What is sort of dog?
Oh my God.
Son Of Dong is like the crazy,
crazy giant fake dick with the giant.
Huge geyser that.
Yeah,
I've seen that.
Those are so weird.
Weird shaped as a penis.
Yeah.
What is that?
That's so because they looked so fake.
Yeah.
It is weird.
Porn is that.
We're a giant fake Dick.
I like watching it though.
The art design and set design is amazing.
You know,
it's a very,
very creative set design with a big stupid fake rubber Dick.
What?
What is this stuff that you've been doing for a.
for Vice magazine Dot Com.
I do this show called fresh off the boat and we use food to get into culture and
we meet all these Weirdos.
Basically the whole point of the show is to travel around the world,
traveling around the United States and find stories and people that other
outlets don't want to talk about.
You know,
what kind of,
what kind of stores.
For instance,
like we went in the bank bus with j Dot Stevens in Miami.
Fritos.
And then you know,
we watched her work and we did that whole episode.
We went to go see him,
watch her do a bang bus.
Yeah.
We watched the whole thing.
So what do they do that they.
You put her in the bus.
It was reversed bus,
right?
So they put her in the back of the bus.
They drive around and they pick up dudes off the street to just bang,
here's the trailer.
What's a reverse bus?
The reverse buses.
Her going in and doing that,
the bank was normally is a dude driving around and find chicks on the street,
a reverse bosses her looking for and then other shows we've done is we went to
go.
We didn't want to separate people from the slaughter because we want people to
know you're eating food,
you're eating animal protein and animal is slaughtered.
So the first episode we ever did was showing like a white rabbit being
slaughtered.
I saw that one.
Do you like it?
Yes.
We're like a pretty thoughtful food show and we try to challenge people really
want to challenge them.
We don't just give them candy is not just.
So we really want them to think about,
you know,
the culture that,
that they're engrossed in the cultures that they're supporting and,
and things like that.
Was that the first time you ever killed an animal like that?
No.
You know,
I've,
we've killed animals.
I Cook Chinese food.
So you're always cooking seafood,
cooking live seafood.
And then I've seen chicken slaughtered.
I've never seen a cow slaughter and never seen a pig slaughter,
but I've seen chickens.
I've seen seafood and I saw a rabbit.
Yeah,
rabbit was pretty intense.
it was definitely intense.
Like everybody there was pretty moving because you watch a life leave the earth
in front of you and I'm funny.
Shit was.
I actually thought I died like a week ago in Houston.
It was really funny.
I ate this into cub bubblegum Hash.
They made this beef jerky out of Indycar Bubblegum Hash and high times gave it
to me and so I'm eating it and I didn't remember the kind of dose it ate it all.
I gave like a little piece to my homie.
I get a little piece of my brother and I remember about 30 minutes after I'm
watching like house of cards on Netflix by myself and I'm like,
Yo,
oh my God,
I think I just died.
And I went to my brother and I felt like I couldn't move.
I could like see shit and I couldn't hear shit and I went to my brother and my,
you gotta take me to the hospital.
You've got to take me to the hospital.
He said,
what am I going to take you to the hospital,
motherfucker?
And I was like,
I think I just died.
He's a die in front of me right now.
I'm like,
so you can hear me,
you can see me.
I'm like jumping on here,
but you could see this.
He's like,
dude,
you are not dead.
Go to sleep.
I was like,
you have to take me to the hospital.
I feel like my spirit left my physical body
talking about and so he takes me to the hospital in Houston.
We were there cooking for the all star game and like Dwayne Wade and I'm in the
hospital.
We check in and doctors like what's wrong?
It's like I think my spirit left.
My physical body is like,
what the fuck did you do as like eight in the bubblegum has jerky and he's like,
you need to chill the fuck out.
You need to just chill the fuck out because there was nothing anyone can do for
you.
I was like,
did I just dies?
No,
you didn't die as high as fuck and you're being a pussy
way described it.
Indigo bubblegum Hash Jerky.
That's very specific to some chefs.
Shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
We've talked about it a billion times on the podcast,
but a lot of people don't know that when you eat marijuana,
it's a totally different psychoactive experience.
Your body produces something,
goes through your liver and it produces something called a one pass and it makes
this chemical called 11 hydroxy metabolite and it's four to five times more
psychoactive than thc in smokable form,
so it's not the same drug.
Can You die from that shit?
No,
no,
no.
The only way you're going to die from drink,
drink milk,
right?
Just trust me.
If you'll calm down like within five minutes does not scientifically about
listening to him.
He doesn't know what the fuck you're going to throw up milk that's just need a
little glass of milk.
Just listen.
That's not scientific.
Brian.
You're talking nonsense because I eat as much hash is that you're fucked.
You're not going to a glass of milk.
It's not going to make me feel fine,
but I ate fucking oldest fucking Hash jerky and I never felt so bad.
I felt like I did heroin.
Yeah,
I can get you really scary high.
You can get to the point where it's really uncomfortable,
you know?
And that's that shit.
It's not fun to go to a hospital and tell people your spirit animals broken.
No,
no,
but I,
I did think that I fucked up.
I went too far.
I've,
I've gotten there before.
We'd just like.
But I always liked that I liked,
I liked what it feels like when it's over,
you're like me and weed are fighting because it's like I love this space for so
long and I'm like,
you really hurt me.
You really hurt me.
This do edibles.
Edibles are amazing,
but it's all in the dosage.
It's very tricky.
I'd love that.
A bowl.
So I prefer edibles
for regular Ed.
A bleeder?
Yeah.
I prefer it.
I think it's better for your body.
I think it's better for your body and I think the,
the intensity of the experience,
it lasts longer and to me it's more introspective.
I learn more.
Oh,
you definitely think of wild shit.
I was like,
I was saying,
I felt like I was one of those Christian inspirational people because I'm in the
car.
Like,
Evan,
you have to realize that every day you have to fight to stay alive because as
soon as you stop you will die.
I just thought,
I swear to God,
I just started watching house of cards.
He's like,
you did not die.
Shut the fuck up.
Just don't watch anymore.
Kevin Spacey Movies.
Did you ever see the,
um,
the nine one,
one call where the cops stole some pot from some kids,
made some pot brownies and then the cops called nine slash 11
and that's the thing.
They thought they died.
They thought that the time it stopped
calling in nine slash 11,
just shitting their pants thinking that this is the end.
No,
I thought I heard like the universe,
his voice was like,
Eddie,
you've checked out.
Like,
I really thought I died.
I was,
ah,
the game is over,
it's over.
I heard the theme.
Music to game is over.
You can definitely too much pot,
but then after it's over,
you feel fine.
It's not even like getting drunk,
you know,
that feeling that you get after you have a hangover.
It's like God damn it.
I don't want to ever Joel that I ate so much.
My head hurt for three days.
Whoa.
I could not.
I did not.
It took me a while to come back.
Three days.
You probably broke something just with anxiety.
Just the anxiety alone was probably so much stress.
Oh yeah.
They're like,
your brain was like
the muscle in my brain.
Fucking hurt.
So yeah,
kids don't eat that fucking bubblegum Hash.
I find that edibles,
make food tastes the best too because I think smoking anything probably Dolan's
your palate a little bit and you have like um,
options out here without a bolts that are fairly delicious.
But,
but also you can actually like pretty much rely on the dose with someone like
candies.
Like,
you know,
like you'll like Ari Shaffir.
I'll ask him like,
what is this?
Candy goes,
it's like a half a breath strip.
Like,
okay,
got it.
But not always.
No,
not always.
It's still not accurate.
You're right.
But some companies like you get used to a company you know,
and they got their shit together and they can make it until the feds come and
buster door down and fucking take him away.
Problem with edibles.
It's also how much you have in your stomach already.
So that's a factor where you know when you smoke it,
you don't have to deal with that.
That's where breast strips come in because it doesn't matter because it just
goes into your bloodstream.
Crazy
sophisticated out here on
the west coast,
kid it.
How hard is it getting good weed in New York?
Yo,
I got a really good service.
I have served that.
They come through and they always have seven to eight strands every time.
But before I met these dudes,
life was miserable.
It was just like sour or haze or,
or,
or Kush.
It's just hard to find someone that you actually want to know your phone number
that's selling weed and these dudes are adults.
They don't show what you,
they don't fucking try to like hang out and get to know your life in and out.
Like give me the best weed and I'll see you later and I'll call you next time.
So that's what you need.
But it does not touch California like California is on some shit.
It's crazy.
That's the best.
I got a GPA.
Those do.
I'll hook you up.
Those dudes are awesome.
Cool.
Yeah.
The G pen is the best way to smoke because the wax tastes so good.
It's like minty fresh chocolate mint ice cream has g and g pen?
A new type of vaporizer or something?
There's a few of them are going to get you one.
So many of them out.
But have you had an idea lab?
I DAB is the way to go in,
in your home like on the road pen the best but I dabs are fucking crazy.
How do you spell it?
G just.
Yeah,
grateful science.
My boy Chris,
he lives in La.
I'll hook you guys up.
He's the best.
I've.
I've used a lot of them.
Like the plume bypass is not bad,
but the g pen,
it's definitely my favorite so far.
That's the one I use on the show all the time when we shoot on the west coat
shoot whenever we used the g pen.
Yeah,
I want one so bad.
Yeah.
They taste amazing.
The scientists out here that are concocting different ways to take your weed to
doing pretty amazing ways.
They have hunting now.
Yeah.
Well we can spend talk some talk lately about what is the legality of Hash and
all these oils and stuff like that.
So they have this g pen vaporizer.
They sell it online.
Anybody can buy it online because you could any tobacco with it right now.
When you buy this,
what do you do with your stick?
We'd in wax and that you put the essential oil in there.
Yeah.
And then you just have to get that from a dispensary.
But you live in La.
It's no problem.
But what?
How do you get it?
Oh yeah.
I know a guy who knows a guy.
He uses it for tobacco.
Do you have a hard time when you're on the road getting good weed when you're
doing your show?
No.
You know,
fans like people will just bring it right.
they'll,
they'll know and they'll just bring it.
Like when I do book tours,
there's always two or three people at every book event that brings me weird.
And how many of them are cops?
Most of them are Asian children.
Easily.
Just like Asian kids,
you know,
they grew up like me.
Like,
Yo,
I know how you are.
You need this shit.
Those are the best people.
They bring me weed everywhere I go.
That's fun.
That's the best thing about being a public public.
Publicly known president smokes weed.
People will hook you up.
Yeah,
I agree.
Do you smoke pot with people that you meet?
People who know you from the show?
Yeah,
I'll smoke where anyone because I'm not a dude that smokes weed and they can't
function.
I'm a functional.
We do function right,
but do you trust there?
We're like,
what if someone wants a lace you up?
It's no.
Have you been late like me?
No,
but I know a person.
Yes.
One Dude.
Yeah.
No one do see ICP.
Somebody put the PCP in this weed.
Well Damn.
Yeah,
that's hardcore.
I've had a very bad situation I had.
It wasn't like a fan or anything,
but I had somebody give me weed once that was dipped in embalming fluid in that
really ruined my own Bama.
Yeah,
that's what I feel like.
I feel like weed is such a friendly culture.
Like why would you do that to somebody?
Because people are broken.
I mean even the weeds are friendly culture.
There's certain amount of any culture that's going to be broken.
Yeah.
There's people that are just unavoidably fucked up.
So you won't smoke weed people give you one tour?
Yeah.
Not Anymore.
Not after that.
Oh Wow.
When I found out that there was a guy I told the story before but by a cop that
was asking me for Dmt in Cleveland and I knew it was a cop,
I just.
It was the most obvious cop ever because some guy after a show by himself with a
crew cut asked me for details like,
bitch,
what are you talking about?
You really coming and asking me for illegal drug.
Yeah.
The specific ask to.
It's a very specific flavor that you're asking.
Yeah,
it's very specific when the problem is,
if every place was like California,
yeah,
it's smoking anybody,
but every place is not like California and there are places where it's super
illegal.
Like you get caught in Texas,
you know,
like Willie Nelson got arrested in Texas.
I mean if you arrest Willie Nelson for pot,
you're a fucking communist,
you know,
and you,
you really,
you,
you're a fucking,
you're the enemy.
God dammit.
I mean it's pretty decriminalized in America I think in,
in the next five to 10.
Like weed is going to be like California everywhere.
There's still so many people in
jail though.
There's so many people in jail because of it.
And did they.
What did they do with their grandfather?
Those guys in and let everybody out.
I don't know.
I don't think they're gonna they should,
but I don't think they will.
The the laws in a lot of places like Phoenix,
it's real bad.
It's not.
It's not good in taxes.
That's scaring a lot of places.
How many different cities have you gone to do your show?
We've done la,
San Fran,
Miami,
New York,
Taiwan?
Yeah,
five.
So I was Taiwan.
Taiwan was amazing.
Man.
Taiwan is the best time.
One is the best.
What do you speak like?
Yeah,
I speak Mandarin.
Chinese.
Now if you're around Cantonese people,
what happens?
I can't understand what they're saying.
It sounds like they're playing Chinese through guitar.
No,
I got mad cantonese homies,
but no,
I don't understand Cantonese and they barely understand mandarin.
It's tough.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's not just north and south like you got an accent.
It's like really some extra tone.
This read it.
I can read some things.
I know a few words I probably read on like a kindergarten level and I speak on
like a fifth grade,
sixth grade level,
but you speak in a fifth grade,
sixth grade level.
Just because you know some of it not because it's across the board.
Oh No.
Cantonese?
No.
I don't know shit about Cantonese,
but the written is the same.
Or written language is the same.
He's written the written Cantonese is the same.
Yeah.
Oh,
fascinating.
Yeah.
So,
but the way they say it is different.
Cantonese and Mandarin.
So you can read all Cantonese.
No problem.
I think it's the same characters.
I'm pretty sure it's the same case.
So how the fuck is it?
A different language?
It's another tone.
They have another tone when they speak it.
Oh my God.
That's weird.
That's insanity.
Yeah.
What does it sound like?
Like what's the difference?
Can you tell me the difference?
Can you like,
give me like a sentence?
The lomea like they say stuff.
It's bouncier.
It sounds bouncier without like,
without being racist and making fun of it.
You know,
it just sounds to me like you're allowed to make fun.
You're Chinese.
You can let it slide,
but like a no.
It's like,
I'm not even saying words,
but I'm just imitating the sound like a,
you know,
a thing don't die.
They're like super bouncy that way,
but it's different than managing in what way?
What's confused me is fifth tone.
Oh yeah.
But the characters are the same,
but they have a different sound for the characters.
Is that what it is?
Which is kinda crazy.
Wow.
So I'm like,
you like one person would say shoe,
they would have a totally different noise for it,
but if you wrote it down,
you both saw shoe.
Yeah.
Whoa.
You're blowing my mind.
How many people are on it will check this and make sure.
I mean we can check this and make sure,
but I'm almost positive that it is.
I'm pretty positive it is the same language.
How many people were on each like,
I mean there's a million commandment.
Much,
much more speaking mandarin and Cantonese.
How much more Cantonese is just like the southeast of China and Hong Kong.
Wow.
How the fuck does that ever happen?
You know,
they just lost the war because some Mongo type shit.
Wow,
that's good.
So the whole idea of a billion people on a continent is a fucking trip,
man.
Yeah.
And did it.
Did.
It wasn't even a billion people on the whole planet just a little while ago.
Yeah,
man,
we are way too good at making babies and that's why they're trying to limit it.
Yeah.
My Friend Duncan actually have funny thing that he said yesterday that some
people believe that this is such an amazing time to be alive,
that so many souls are trying to reincarnate to this time.
That's why there's so many people on the planet.
Yeah.
Okay.
So they say here,
written Cantonese is the most highly developed written form of all Chinese
varieties apart from standard mandarin and classical standard written Chinese is
based on manner,
but when spoken word for word as Cantonese,
it sounds unnatural because it's expressions or ungrammatical in an idiomatic in
Cantonese.
So Cantonese speakers have developed their own written scripts,
sometimes creating new characters for words that either do not exist or have
been lost in standard Chinese.
But basically it's based on the same language.
Wow.
It's just more refined.
That'd be weird.
Trying to speak English and just speak it differently with using the same words.
Yeah.
What the fuck man.
So uh,
what is it like working with the vice guys were fucking love it.
I love vice man best.
I've worked with so many people and vice just let you do your thing and that's
the best part.
And like I,
I just went through a whole week.
I was at Ted,
I'm a ted fellow this year and I went through a whole week of people telling me
what to do,
where to be and it was like being at a fucking scientology summer camp.
It was horrible.
Tell me what the fuck happened.
They told you that you,
you,
you can't leave yet.
Like before you go there,
you need to participate in Ted,
you need to be.
I'm like alright cool.
I'm,
I figure like mines are reasonable.
If you have to do something in La you can go do something in La.
I gave them like four or five days of my time,
like I was there every single day.
Thirteen hours.
Like everyday they have 13 hours of fucking activities they have mapped out for
you some days,
like 15,
16 hours,
right.
If you go to their after events and I was like that's way too much fucking human
interaction days.
Yeah.
Explain this.
So you go there and you're going to go and do your own Ted speech,
right?
Yeah.
So you do your own Ted speech.
What does the other stuff they have for you?
They want you to be available for like networking,
cocktail events like attendees want to talk to you,
you need to be available.
And I was like,
look,
I,
I've done a lot.
Like I put people on,
like I put them in touch with ad agency people.
I put them in touch with other people to do business with other artists.
I introducing everyone and I thought I was good.
So I went yesterday to go do DVD asa and when met up Cho,
I met an asa and I went and now they call me today on the way over here and they
were like,
we're taking your fed Ted Fellowship where I was like,
why are you taking the Ted Fellowship?
Like because you went to la.
I was like,
Urine Long Beach.
I just went to La for the afternoon to do the fucking podcast.
You're fucking crazy.
And they're like,
you took this spot from somebody who would have gone to every talk and been in
everything.
I was like,
Yo,
the other people weren't there for everything,
but you're also just crazy.
Like you're fucking crazy.
Crazy.
They're not paying,
you know,
they don't pay that since that's going to do it for the love and they want you
for seven days,
12 to 15 hours a day and you can't just leave to go do something.
Some work that you have to do.
It's fucked up.
Yeah.
What,
what is it where people fuck up everything.
Even something as amazing as Ted,
because Ted,
I remember the first Ted talk that I ever saw on the Internet a couple of years
ago.
We have a whole ted thread of my message board about great.
A great ted episodes,
like the one how to be happy is great.
Oh,
there's so many of them are.
Graham Hancock just gave one of the war and consciousness about Iowasca and in
his own problems with kicking cannabis.
He had like a crazy weed habit where he's high all day every day for like
decades.
And then he liked.
He was,
it was a crutch forum.
It was like a real problem.
Um,
great ted talk about it though.
There's so much good stuff,
but then you hear shit like this and you're like,
even they suck.
Like even someone finds a way to fuck up.
Even something as amazing as tad.
The speakers
are great.
I quit.
I can't say damn bad thing.
Every single one of the fellows is like inspirational,
amazing,
doing great work.
The thing is that something gets so good and people feel the power that they
have and then they impose rules and that's how society got created in the
beginning.
Somebody got so liked and got so much power that they could force you to do
things that were entirely unnatural and inhuman.
That's so ridiculous to think that a guy like you who's as busy as you could
give up that much time and be angry if you vary from their schedule at all.
That that sounds like more.
I think Ted's a racist
culturally kind of crazy too because other people missed and they kind of picked
on me for it,
but even before I got out and I was like,
Yo,
my birthday is Friday.
You want me to stay till Saturday?
Can I at least have my girls stay with me and I'll just use the room.
Like,
oh we can't because you have a roommate at Ted,
so you're like 30,
40 year old people staying with a roommate.
I was like,
wait a minute.
They make you room with people.
Wait a minute.
Why?
How can they do that?
Tell you who to sleep with.
Yeah,
they were.
Yes,
and they were like,
you have to room.
It's part of the Ted experience and I was like,
this is a ct at this point you have crossed the thrust of are now fucking
scientology.
Yes.
That's crazy.
So they assign you.
They say,
you know what?
We think that Eddie would grow if he lived with Sasha for a week.
Yeah.
So some crazy fuck.
Who's Sasha Shogun?
Who's in there cooking up crystal meth and whatever the fuck he is doing.
He,
you'd have to stay with that guy.
I mean luckily with this dude software who is amazing.
Cool cat.
Yeah,
you were really to be able to pull the name of the dude is amazing.
His name was southwest and I stayed with him,
but I was like,
I'm 30.
I haven't stayed in a hotel with people in a minute.
You know?
How big is the hotel?
It's a small shitty hotel.
It's the height reasons.
It looks like a fucking airport hotel in la,
in the bed next to this guy.
So you have to hear each other's snore.
Oh Dude,
what the fuck is that?
And they also hold this shit at long beach and it's like next to like across the
street,
literally you have back to back out,
back pf Chang's and like subway.
It's ridiculous.
But the whole thing is just weird.
I was like,
I'll pay for my own room.
They're like,
no,
you're not allowed.
I was like,
you're not allowed to pay for your own room.
Yeah,
they're crazy.
They just want to control you.
That is amazing.
So I still love the talks.
I love all the speakers,
but the organization is fucked.
That's hilarious that they think that they can have that kind of influence over
you.
It's part of the Ted experience as part of the Ted experience.
It's part of the Ted experience.
No one's talked about this before because this seems like straight up boy
scouts.
Yeah.
You know what is the thing is most people they need 10.
They need to put you on.
They want the coastline and most people it's like if you do something for me,
I won't say anything about you,
but that's.
I mean,
I think Joe,
you're the same way.
I don't give a fuck what you do for me.
If you're a fucking Weirdo and you're about to start some new coat conference,
religion,
I'm going to say something.
I'm not going to follow your rules.
I would write a book about this by trade.
They actually tried to get me to do what they wanted me to do for four,
five,
six,
seven days,
whatever it was,
and not paying you.
They send packets to to be like,
this is how to network with billionaires.
Like how to go to work with billionaires,
how to go to a network and talk to people and talk to potential people who could
collaborate and work with you.
They're like,
don't just go ask them for money.
And I'm like,
this is crazy.
Oh my God,
I'm so go ask them for money and it's in the packets and you're a grown ass man
and they pick you like you're obviously intelligent if you're getting picked for
10 and they're like,
today when it rains,
you should pack a punch.
It's wild.
See?
That would.
That is hard.
Okay.
What that is is exactly the opposite of the vehicle that got them there and the
vehicle that got them there is the Internet.
What?
What got them there is the fact that the freedom of the Internet allows people
to exchange interesting conversations like that,
hey,
you gotta,
listen to this.
You gotta wash us.
This lady gave the speech on monkeys.
It was amazing.
Whatever.
And what they did is the exact opposite of that and that's why even though Obama
is focusing on gun control,
the most important debate that Americans will face in the next five years is
internet freedom.
Internet freedom is the most important debate we will face.
And we hurt so fucking blind to it because the lobbyists are doing it under like
under our noses.
Yeah,
you,
you surely should have the right and ability to put your own website up and
control your own content and express yourself in any,
in any way,
shape form you choose.
And the benefits of that have been staggering to our culture over the last
couple of years.
Yeah,
just just over the last 10,
you know,
and the idea that corporations might have the ability to step in and stop that
or regulate that or restrict that or sensor you if in anything that you do and
somehow or another,
if anything you do and somehow or another a one way or a forms cost them money
and they decide that this is something that has to be stopped.
They're going to be able to do that.
Unless West we do something and when somebody realizes they have their hand on
the faucet and they have the ability to turn it on and turn it off,
people get crazy.
You've seen that study.
It's like Ted,
like these 10 people power.
Yeah.
They do this shit where they invite these people to go talk and they actually
don't put up everybody's talks until this year.
They used to pick and choose and cherry pick the talks they put up and you would
go there for a week,
15 hours a day,
do all their shit and then imagine if they didn't put up your talk.
But what have you talked socks.
If you're talk sucked,
I feel like it should just go suck on the internet or on the Internet,
you know?
Right.
But maybe yes and no,
because if,
if you say if you had a comedy conference and uh,
you had all these comedians do sets,
but some of them were just dog shit.
You want that set to represent your,
your company?
No,
you would.
You know,
you wouldn't do it.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
you know,
if I did though,
invite someone and they stayed for a week and I didn't pay them,
I would be like,
the least I owe you is opportunity that quite possibly there's three people on
the planet or at that enjoy your son.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's one point.
Yeah,
that's a point.
I guess if I know what you're saying,
to protect the brand,
it makes a little sense,
but you know,
for the most part,
most people's talks are fucking good.
Yeah.
They're there for a reason,
so it's probably really different than going to get an open miker Ted Talker,
but it's not a bringer show here.
Right.
But they give opportunities to a lot of weird people mean it.
It's absolutely possible.
There must be.
I bet if we just ask a bit,
we're ignorant to it,
but we just say,
show me the Ted talks.
That sucker fat Dick.
Okay.
Twitter,
twitter people,
please show me the Ted talks that soccer fat dick one wants to see the Sarah
Silverman.
Ted Talk.
There was never let out.
She gave.
She gave us never let happen.
No,
they never let it out because she made fun of Ted.
See,
I would've fucking wanted to watch that immediate.
Really.
And the thing is,
if you're confident in is that you're allowed,
you can laugh at yourself.
They don't know how to laugh at themselves.
She made fun of Ted.
In what way?
Like during her talk,
it's like the mythology of it.
I didn't see the talk obviously,
but was the Sarah Silverman Ted talk?
They never let out.
Wow.
We need to get serious.
I
need to run into her somewhere.
I could.
I couldn't make it happen.
Okay.
Am I going to happen her?
Um,
I,
I've never heard anything bad about ted before,
so that's why this is such a shock.
It is weird though.
You meet the donors and stuff and they can't tell Asian people apart.
They can't tell African people apart and it's just,
it's weird man.
They're nice and everybody means well.
Did they call you David Choe?
No.
They mistake you for other fellows because so many of them are Asian.
Really?
That's funny.
Yeah.
How many different people do it every year?
Every year they pick like 20 fellows and then they pick a bunch of other people
for the main stage.
So yeah,
I mean,
no it is.
It is a ill organization.
I still,
even though they booted me today,
I,
I love the speakers.
I love the talks and I want it to continue,
but I hope that they,
at least,
you know,
they could say I suck and that's fine.
They can be like,
Eddie's a shithead.
He went to la,
he did the fucking podcast and he sucks,
but I hope they just changed the rules for future people.
So there's something you didn't do anything wrong.
They're crazy and all they represent is a distribution method for the greatest
minds on earth.
That's all they represent.
It's not the baby are the greatest minds on earth.
It's just there's so many interesting people today.
We live in an amazing time and just when you good,
something like Ted,
whatever that Ted stands for,
it became synonymous on the Internet with fascinating talks.
Boom.
And then it's off.
Yeah.
You could do the Eddie Wong's,
you know,
fascinating.
Motherfuckers on bias and do the exact same thing.
Yeah,
I think there's a lot of room for that because conferences like I would love to
hear more people from downtown La,
downtown New York and talking and doing these ideas because they don't find
those dudes.
They find academics,
they find people playing ancient instruments.
They find people that are,
you know,
working nature things and,
and they have their kind of like cultural sect,
you know,
but there is a lot of room to find genius and other places,
geniuses everywhere you know this,
you travel around the world,
you find genius anywhere.
So there's room for conferences that like look under different cultures because
they're kind of looking under the same stones all the time.
Right.
And they're going to run out of bugs and I'm one of the.
I'm one of the first time they've stepped out to be like,
all right,
there's this dude,
he's Chinese.
He's into hip hop.
He lives in downtown New York.
He used to sell drugs.
He now has a restaurant.
I think I was the only working chef that was a ted fellow.
So I,
I was one of their choices that was really out there,
but it just didn't work out,
but it didn't work out because you're not willing to be a fucking slave and
sleep in a hotel room with a stranger for a week.
Yeah,
that's insane.
I rehearsed for two days.
I fucking did the PTO.
I did everything I'm supposed to do and then I was like,
I'm going to just piece out for like a half day.
And they bugged.
Wow.
You know you,
that's,
that's crazy.
And it's the fact that they don't pay you.
It's crazy.
You guys need to do a vice show exposing Ted tabs.
I told vice that I,
I told him that before I got booted.
I sent them an email like,
Yo,
you got to see this shit.
It's like the beginnings of scientology.
Wow.
It is so true that once people have a position of power and influence and people
want to be a part of them,
people go corrupt.
Yup.
What is the threshold at which something becomes a religion?
You know,
it's kind of insane.
It's so easy to start a cult today.
There's so many people looking to jump on board,
you know,
all the people that would have 100 years ago become Catholics now.
They're like,
man,
Pope just won't stop fucking kids.
I can't do this.
I needed a new cult.
I don't know why people still believe in these.
Really like you look at what these people are doing,
like what these.
What's happening in the Catholic church is insane.
Fucking popes resigning because the first time it's gotten so hot that the
pope's like,
I'm Outta here.
He's asked for immunity from the Catholic,
from the Italian government,
from prosecution because he's responsible for shielding pedophiles.
He personally,
and a lot of people don't know this,
the pope personally responsible for taking pedophiles and shifting them away to
another place where they molested more kids.
And what would you expect?
You don't.
These people aren't allowed to have sex.
It's natural to want to have sex.
It's natural to want to go to La and do podcasts.
You know,
as soon as you cannot come to Ted and have sex without condoms,
I'd be like,
fuck that.
You,
you imagine no unprotected sex.
There's no raw dogging.
Attend illegal.
No Ass fucking while you're here.
Oh Man.
You're a ted fellow.
There would be a mutiny.
I wonder if they would have like you,
you could slowly start imposing behavior standards.
You know,
on fellows,
you know,
if you want to call it like a ted fellow or,
or whatever new organization you want to start.
They do shit.
Like you should have a standing.
You should give a standing ovation when this person calls me,
you should do this and that.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Fake standing ovations.
Yeah.
And they were also saying like,
you know,
when the founder comes,
Chris Anderson comes like,
you don't have to give him a standing ovation.
Like,
you know,
it's nice if you want to,
but he doesn't actually need you to do it.
I'm like the fact that you needed to give me this fake halfway disclaimers.
So fucking strange.
Wow.
That's so strange.
Are they tell you who to and not to give standing ovations to who's allowed to
apply.
You have to apply to go to Ted to attend and then once you're accepted you pay
$8,000.
That's a mind.
Fuck.
Wait a minute.
You had to pay.
No.
Hell No.
I'm like,
okay.
So the people that attend these strict audience members are saying,
Oh,
you gotta want to be so down so bad to do that,
to go through an application process and then fucking pay.
That's a lot of money.
How many people are going?
How many people go?
I don't know.
I think,
uh,
like 2000,
3000.
Holy Shit.
That's a lot of money.
They make.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That's a lot of money.
They make off of you.
Yeah.
Two thousand people paying $8,000 is how much?
A six,
300.
60,000.
What is it?
One hundred $60,000.
No,
be more.
it's way more than that.
It's like $16 million I think,
but yeah,
$2,000 times 16 million.
Two thousand 10.
You don't know shit about your numbers and I didn't even bother to count Asian
always.
I'm asking agents from now on $60 million in use.
Silly Birch,
what is it,
Brian?
Do you ever calculator built in what's number 2000 times a thousand?
Be Sixteen dollars million.
What's 2000 times $8,000?
This might answer your question.
Uh,
it is
one point $6 million I think.
Oh,
one point 6 million.
That was one off.
I was excited.
Okay.
That makes sense.
A lot of bread.
So they made one point 6 million.
Sixteen million.
16 million human calculator was fast.
Very nice.
So,
um,
they made 16 million,
which is even crazier.
And they did this in this time where you were there and no one got paid.
Paid.
Nobody got paid.
Wow.
Yup.
We're suckers.
Dude.
Why soccer?
And they're always telling you like you're going to get exposure.
It was like no lie.
More people listening to the Joe Rogan experience.
That's true.
Ted.
Suck it Ted.
We got you beat by like a million,
but that's still nuts,
man.
That's a lot of money.
We're not making that money.
We need to make that money.
People.
Joe Rogan.
$10,000,000 each.
I know how to do it.
I'm going to just raise the bar and only get really stupid rich people.
I'm not,
you know,
I don't want to like go after poor people because I think that's rude.
So a million.
You got bolt soon.
My bad.
No,
that's all right.
You have.
What are you doing next?
What do you got going on?
I got it.
I got a meeting,
you know,
La meetings and BC shit.
Bullshit.
Bullshit,
dude.
My bad.
What are you going to do next?
Is Go to another show you're working on after the show.
Uh,
yeah.
Tell us,
give us,
you know,
to be on NBC.
We optioning the book like the real is going to become a sitcom.
We want to.
Margaret Cho moratorium has been lifted,
right?
The Margaret Cho Moratorium on Asian television has been lifted.
We want to do a sitcom from,
from the books.
So that's fascinating.
Like Chelsea lately.
Yeah.
Well I have not seen that,
but all I know is my dad's dream was to be Al Bundy and hopefully someone can
play it.
Al Bundy.
Like my dad.
Wow.
Are you going to lock Bobby Lee up to a longterm deal right now?
I will show.
I was kinda hoping run our tests would go yellow face.
So what can they do with CGI?
Did the,
what's his name and Tron.
Can they do that with an American actor?
Could they do that?
Just have some family.
There's five people I kind of want to just get the like Michigan Fab five
together and yellow face go yellow face.
Just tape.
It is funny.
What was that?
Networks?
Which Asian actor would you want to be like?
I Dunno,
just get the fab five to go yellow face.
There was um,
there was a Chinese,
a Chinese investigator that they used to Charlie Chan.
And in the movie it was a white guy that played Charlie Chan.
Do you know that?
The original Charlie Chan?
Yeah,
the original Charlie Chan was,
um,
it was uh,
some old dude.
Hold on a second.
Charlie Chan was like this wise old school.
A detective.
But yeah,
it was played by Warner.
Oh land.
It wasn't Chinese at all.
Look at him.
Yeah.
No,
a lot of people went yellow face back in the day.
I mean that's a lariat.
When did they start?
You got to leave,
but when did they start acting?
Adding a Asian actors?
Two roles at allowing agents to play roles.
It was probably gremlins.
One
big trouble.
China,
like no white people want to be around this Gremlin.
Wow.
Next time I come back again,
come back to school day.
You're in the house,
brother.
Thank you.
And please go by Eddie's book.
It is called fresh off the boat.
It is available on audible.com.
You can go to audible.com forward slash joe and you can get that book for free
if you'd like,
and you also get a 30 day free.
Can we get to take a picture of you before you leave?
We gotta to take a 30 day free membership to audible.com and it's one of our
sponsors,
audible.com.
Forward Slash Joe.
Thank you also to on it.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com,
o n n I t user code named Brogan.
Save yourself 10 percent off any and all supplements.
We will be back Sunday night with Dr Steven greer.
He is that super smart dude who claims that he speaks to aliens.
He's the guy from the disclosure project and uh,
he's,
he's not a loon is going to be very fascinating,
but it's going to be late.
It'll be 8:00 California time on Sunday.
So,
uh,
go check it out this Friday and Saturday.
Me and my little buddy Brian and our past,
Sam motherfucking Tripoli are going to be in.
Oh,
hi.
we will be at the theater on Friday in Cincinnati and the palace theater and
Columbus on Saturday.
And then we will see you back here in cyberspace Sunday night for the crazy
Steven greer ufo revelation podcast.
My Dick is hard just thinking about this,
although that's probably not what Mr. greer wants to hear him being a
distinguished gentleman of science.
You don't want to hear someone's Dick is hard to meet you,
but it is so deal with that.
All right.
We love the shit out of you guys.
And uh,
we couldn't be happier with everything.
So we'll see you soon.
Hopefully keep it together.
Bitches love yourself as you would love other people and that and this and the
other thing.